public speaking is a skill useful in
school at work and if we want to
convince a group of people investor
Warren Buffett called it the most
important skill we can learn to advance
in a career here is a short sprouts
guide to master the most powerful weapon
if we want to bring change to the world
[Music]
the issue take an issue you really care
about when you study it you are
intrinsically motivated to learn about
it more deeply and put in the extra
effort later it gives you the passion
you need to inspire your audience when
we speak in public
passion is probably a most powerful
force it shines through our eyes and
straight into the hearts of the audience
one simple message every issue has many
angles which we can highlight but the
audience has a limited attention span
and many other issues in life so if we
say too much they will lose interest to
make a message stick Chris Anderson
recommends to boil it down to one idea
that is worth spreading a speech is good
if it plans one creative seed in the
heads of the audience a seed can then
grow into a sprout which can change
lives and be shared with others
structure over 2,000 years ago the Greek
philosopher Aristotle established three
simple rules to any good speech
establish credibility ethos give good
arguments logos conveying emotions pay
for which you can also tell a personal
story or present a problem and then
offer a solution get help a good method
is using note cards you can use one card
per argument and keep the deck in your
hands alternating them as you speak
politicians often read their speech from
a teleprompter professionals often sell
their ideas with the help of slides when
you have a product to show demonstrate
it if you try to memorize your speech if
you have one hour spend 20 minutes
studying and 40 minutes practicing
reciting it that's usually the best race
speak their language it doesn't matter
what we say it matters what they hear
according to nerd writer
Donald Trump speaks in a way that means
any fourth grader can understand him Guy
Kawasaki recommends to use what he calls
salient points people don't want to know
how large a battery is they want to know
how long they can use it when you
prepare ask yourself does my issue
matter to this particular audience
[Music]
practice before you present practice
your delivery it's important that we
stand upright arms open arms out you
should speak loud and clear and make eye
contact with our audience one way to
practice is to try speaking in front of
friends who don't know the topic then
you will see if they get your point
alternatively you could record and watch
yourself on video check your stage how
big is the room how many people will
listen will you need a microphone
professionals will want to walk onto the
stage diagonally from the left back
apparently it's the most dynamic way to
make an entrance
also always have a glass of water next
to you so you can take a sip whenever
you're losing it don't be afraid
everybody can experience speech anxiety
also known as glossophobia it's natural
and sometimes actually helps us to reach
excellence Mahatma Gandhi called it the
awful strain of public speaking for
years it prevented him from speaking up
even at friendly dinner parties but in
1942 Gandhi convinced 60,000 people with
his quit India speech to join a peaceful
revolt against British colonialism he
spoke up that people followed his words
and a British left
open for sympathy when you enter the
limelight wait until you have everyone's
full attention then open to win sympathy
a technique also called capped RTO
Beneful nti one way to do that is to
excuse yourself you can say you were a
smart audience so I don't really know
what I can still tell you Obama opened
his 2008 speech in Berlin with the words
I have to admit that I have developed a
special place in my heart for the German
people and they loved it build curiosity
once they like you grab their attention
by building curiosity present a fact
statistics or a study or start in the
middle of a story on my fifth birthday
my father started crying it was the day
he lost his job then enjoy a hit you
rocki a champion of public speaking
asked raise your hand if you have an
emotional mother and everyone did but
you can also do something funny or open
with a crazy stunt deliver your message
now make your arguments share those
personal stories and deliver metaphors
which create images in the minds of your
audience if you forget what you wanted
to say don't worry nobody knows what you
meant to say in 1963 Martin Luther King
gave a speech in Washington in the
middle of it we stopped reading from the
script and started to improvise he
delivered one of the greatest speeches
of the twentieth century I have a dream
close after you were done summarize your
arguments or repeat the core message but
you can also leave them with a quote
share your dream of a new future or
close your speech like we close our
videos with a specific call for action
here it comes
right to speech about an important issue
such as education open with sympathy
build curiosity and then bring in your
convincing argument in the end close it
cleverly limit your speech to 200 words
and post it in the comments below if you
want to learn public speaking you should
also practice your speech for example
over the next 5 days
spend 15 minutes practicing each day
ideally record yourself on your phone so
you can track your progress and learn
from your mistakes upload the last try
of each day on to YouTube and share the
link in the comments then we can see how
you progressed and applaud you for
trying failing and doing
[Music]
[Music]